how's it going breast my name is
and welcome back to some more dark souls
today is the day we're gonna champion
i read your rose comments and apparently
you can kill the pig by a very sneaky
special method
by stabbing it in the ass let's do it
too bad it will take me like three years
to get there
i'm so sick of this area holy [ __ ] hit
me with your best
shot i should hit me with your best shot
am i supposed to read these okay we're
gonna try to kill the pig
this is gonna be hard man oh [ __ ] he
doesn't look happy so apparently he's
like sensitive towards fire
so that's what we're gonna use against
him oh god
i should clear the area first actually
oh my [ __ ] god
come here i know you want my ass
yeah the fire does damage him a little
bit now the plan the plan
is to not die that's the number one plan
i think he's blind because sometimes
when i'm standing still he doesn't do
anything
did he hear that no he did not see
he doesn't know [ __ ] oh if that was real
life i'd be dead by now
i didn't do a lot let me stab you in the
ass let me stab you in the ass
girl i want to take you out for dinner
and then i'm gonna stab you in the air
that who put that armor on that [ __ ]
thing is a [ __ ] idiot man
hey yo you're ugly ugly ugly ugly
you gotta penetrate there we go and in
three years maybe he'll actually be dead
penetration ah well some people just
aren't into it i guess
you can't blame me i wasn't the one who
decided you wouldn't have armor on your
ass
you're sad man you're a sad man man
you may have haunts as big as my penis
would ever dream of being
oh god oh god oh god but i have an ass
stabber
and it works you're my [ __ ] now mr
piggy
no loot no loot all right well at least
he won't respawn
so now we can just like rush through
here and we don't have to go around
everything
there we go mr knight is dead mr knight
has come to say good night get it
i definitely hear someone there no i
don't have time for you man
holy [ __ ] i almost died
one little piece of [ __ ] can just take
your ass and
put into little pieces of sand and then
[ __ ] sniff it
what you never try that well don't judge
unless you tried it man
yep the boar is gone that's one plus i
guess
and we're back just gotta make it to
that [ __ ] campfire bonfire you come
first please
you that's right jimmy you're fast thank
you jimmy for your cooperation
it's most gratitude i don't even know if
that's a word jimmy
i [ __ ] your girlfriend jimmy does that
make you angry jimmy
you can talk to me jimmy talk to me when
you're [ __ ] dead jimmy
why don't you ever go any new places
jimmy there you go have fun jimmy
nope nope nope
and now you [ __ ] die so far so good
it's supposed to be here i never made it
this far
yes high [ __ ] five yes
oh spin a while bonfire
well awkwardly close we're standing i
want to sell you all my [ __ ]
am i wearing a thong whoa what is this
oh hey blondie oh you look good have you
seen my thong
i know the game was multiplayer but what
what's happening please for the love of
god be nice i'll kneel to you
i'll suck is he gonna kill him yeah
that's right go girl
kill him oh not me holy [ __ ] he kills me
like two hits
oh my god let's get the loot before he
kills me
i don't want to risk anything oh god no
don't die wesley
wesley you died i'll give you bj's
that's not good to see yay moko now kill
people for me
oh over here over here moko ladies fast
you have the blonde hair after all come
on i'm wearing a thong and you're
wearing badass armors you go first
oh god it's the guy with a polar bear
all right let's kill him man i should
just let someone else play the entire
game for me
is this where we say goodbye oh he's
fabulous
oh they're coming with me cool
what is happening well this place is
beautiful this game is gorgeous man
so is my thong just want to point that
[ __ ] out oh no
oh no hey let's not judge on their
appearance they may have great
personalities okay and i'm not gonna
take any chances holy [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
dead
oh god not me it kanye rouka puku save
me i'll just
be here uh uh making sure nothing bad
happens
okay i'm not gonna summon more people i
just wanted to kind of try it out
man it's gotta be cold just wearing this
what happens if we ring the bell
oh man that's sexy ass
oh what the [ __ ] what are you doing
all right so now we have a holbert
badass x
beautiful helmet and a sweet-ass ass
let's go it says i can't use it i don't
know what that means it doesn't do any
damage at all
oh no come on be nice oh god
oh god i'm sorry okay this is gonna be a
big problem
i don't know how i'm gonna fight the
rats i really don't know how i'm gonna
fight the rats
i hate it if i die here that would make
me genuinely
upset okay let's just go with the butt
stab
the rats are everywhere they're crazy oh
god don't poison
fun fun okay okay plan b
run before the poison kills you excuse
me sir i have other [ __ ] things to do
in my life
we came so far to lose it all
in the end i have a sweet ass song
how many times am i gonna pull that joke
no one knows as mama pirates always said
if you don't twerk then
don't do it that [ __ ] actually
what my mom was a wise man what
well you can't tell about the way i use
my walk i'm a walmart me
don't try to talk bells oh two nights
good cause
cause i thought one was too easy
damn skills brother not today sir
we did it i'm getting a little better
i'm not terrible anymore that's what i
would say
you know what i have a plan b on these
[ __ ] i have a plan
it's not it's not a good idea but it's
not the worst of ideas either
whoa you stupid [ __ ]
no i'm poison don't panic there's plenty
of time before you get poisoned
this is pale that's
not gonna die from a you're not gonna
die from you drink drink drink dinner
where is it i don't where is
for this don't you dare kill me
it's up there
i [ __ ] up in the stupidest ways and we
are back with our vedas
okay we are back at the rats
all right the plan yeah the plan what is
the plan here
oh god does he see me
you're mean stop oh [ __ ] me in the ass
we may be poisoned
but that is no reason to rush we have
all the time you're not coming with me
you piece of rat where's the bonfire
where's the where's the [ __ ] bonfire
man
let's rest i wonder ken told me about
this i'm supposed to stand here
or some [ __ ] like that how do i aim with
it
that is punch what are you doing i just
found out you can't aim with a crossbow
i just did all that [ __ ] for nothing
this [ __ ] game all right so i
upgraded my sword it's probably not the
best idea
but i needed i need a better weapon
that's just all i know
man these are so easy now like before oh
never mind oh god
oh god where are we going this is pretty
far down i don't know what i feel about
this
whoa what is that what is that
is that a bird is that a plane
is that an elephant's eye hey little bad
you're so cute
oh sorry birdie sorry buddy yeah yeah
come on i know you're grumpy and [ __ ]
but god let me get the loot
so i didn't show this in my first
episode because i didn't think this is
going to be a series but that guy told
us that
we needed to ring the bell i remember
now and then high up
and then now we need to go down low as
[ __ ] alright see you guys let's see how
easy you guys are now
pretty easy
having so much trouble with these little
guys
oh he's just gonna lay down and burn
okay we can beat him probably not oh
[ __ ]
definitely not maybe we can just take it
here you walk
right into my trap
and that's how you get a blue tear stone
is this the door
oh my god i found the door mama papa
look at me
so this is where i was supposed to go i
spent a good about hour just walking
around like a [ __ ] idiot
whoa we really are going on huh
y'all whoa
nailed it where the hell are we i like
the place
well this place needs a makeover god
somebody
please let me out of here hey anybody
oh hi how are you unlock the door
i did i'm finished but i'm right here
this ever happened
i'm right here man what's that guy doing
inside that barrel
oh that's hot be wary of tears what the
hell does that even mean
oh what what stop it
i like it's all green oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
god damn not doggies
i don't need no shield [ __ ] slay you
all [ __ ]
oh oh you're drinking huh well you're
dying too
[ __ ] oh hello doggy
goodnight doggy sleep well one by osh
[ __ ] off
oh i'm so much faster now this is really
nice all right let's go through
i'm sure nothing bad will happen oh come
on
what the hell i don't even get to look
at him well that should be fun
let's enjoy that in the next episode
shall we leave a like if you enjoyed
watching
hit subscribe comment today see you
brother the next one i really appreciate
all the support thank you both
it's awesome stay awesome
these times are too tight man oh the
brake has someone
nailed it